et alors que les moyens de lutte contre
la pollution sont mises en oeuvre
l'enquêté se poursuit cinq membres
d'équipage sont actuellement en garde à
vue et entendus par la gendarmerie dans
le cadre d'une enquête pour mise en
danger d'autrui
il est apparu en effet que le navire
était en mauvais état qu'il avait
demandé à se réfugier dans le port de
saint nazaire une escale que le
commandant de bord lui a refusé voici
l'instant filmé par la marine nationale
ou la coque de l'erika s'est brisé en
deux c'était dimanche matin à 80 km des
côtes bretonnes
on voit jaillir du pétrolier éventrés
des petits nuages noirs ce sont les
flots de fioul dix minutes plus tard le
navire sera coupée en deux morceaux
comment en est on arrivé là c'est la
question à laquelle va tenter de
répondre la justice dès hier le parquet
de paris a ouvert une enquête un juge
d'instruction devrait être chargée
demain de cette affaire de mise en
danger d'autrui
mais d'ores et déjà cinq des 26 membres
indien de l'équipage de l'erika secouru
dimanche sont en garde à vue interrogé
par la gendarmerie maritime
parmi eux figurent le capitaine et le
second du pétrolier ce navire battant
pavillon maltais loué par la firme total
fina avait été construit il ya 25 ans
mais il avait subi trois contrôles au
cours des derniers mois dont un en
france samedi après midi pourtant
l'équipage a découvert une avarie grave
une fissure dans la coque difficile à
contenir il a alors demandé à faire
escale dans le port de saint nazaire
mais le commandant du port a refusé pour
éviter semble-t-il tout risque de
pollution de la loire le commandant
alain chung aurait cependant aussitôt
prévenu la préfecture maritime de brest
mais en vain le pétrolier maltais qui
continue à faire route vers le sud dans
la tempête n'a pu aller plus loin